there has been major drama as to whether  bernie sanders would support the  reelection of joe biden some people  hoping bernie would say i would primary  joe biden well bernie has now come out  and said i would never primary joe biden  that would be a bad idea and if he is  the nominee i will support joe biden in  2024. now um  there is a question as to whether joe  biden is going to run for reelection we  don't have the answer yet the the white  house has been using the phrase  biden intends to run that's very  different than biden is running or has  decided to run biden intends to run as a  sort of a different phrase  but i understand why this is the  position bernie's taking it would be  listen  i'm not like a big biden fan you know  i've talked about i really like jamie  raskin i like john ossoff i like stacey  abrams there's lots of people i find  more interesting  but strategically primaring biden is not  a good idea so i'm with bernie on this i  think bernie's right